let's examine the velocities of an
objects in the center-of-mass reference
frame so we have object one and object
two and we have cm and we have r1 prime
and we have our two prime and recall
that we found that the position vector
r1 prime was equal to the reduced mass
over mu m1 times the relative position
vector r1 - I'll draw that up here
r1 2 from 2 to 1 and just to remind you
are 1 minus r2 and likewise the position
vector R 2 prime is minus mu em 2 over R
1 2 well now we can differentiate the
positions in the center-of-mass frame
and we find that V 1 which is of course
the derivative of the position is just
mu over m 1 V 1 2 and the 2 prime is
equal to MU over m 2 with a minus sign
the 1 2 now the significance of this
result is that the velocity of the
object in the center-of-mass frame is
equal to some constant times the
relative velocity likewise velocity V 2
Prime in the center-of-mass frame is
also proportional to a constant and it's
in - the relative velocities so the
significance of this result is that when
we looked at an elastic one-dimensional
collision we already have the result
that the relative velocities V 1 -
initial is - the final relative velocity
and we also know from what we saw that
the relative velocity is independent of
the reference frame
so this condition about relative
velocity is true in any reference frame
and in particular it's true in the
center-of-mass frame so what that shows
us is that this conditions the statement
is that the magnitude of the relative
velocity is constant and the conclusion
is because in the center-of-mass frame
v1 prime is proportional to the relative
velocity that tells us that in the
center-of-mass reference frame that the
initial velocity of object one in the
center-of-mass frame is equal to the
final velocity of object one so the
quantity the speed of objects 1 and
objects two in an elastic collision in
the center-of-mass reference frame do
not change magnitude we can call this
quantity v1 Prime and likewise the prime
to initial is equal to v2 final time the
two prime and this will make our
analysis of collisions in the center of
mass reference frame very easy two
objects when they're colliding in the
center of mass reference frame their
speeds do not change only the direction
of their velocities change